cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com first Abram's tanks arrive
in Ukraine zielinski says U.S officials
said that an initial batch of 31 M1
Abrams Tanks promised to Ukraine by the
Biden Administration have been delivered
months ahead of estimates and it's not
just that it's also this
60 Minutes reported just the other day
it was discovered that the U.S is
financing more than weapons in Ukraine
the government is buying seeds
fertilizer for Farmers paying the
salaries of 57 000 First Responders and
subsidizing small businesses I call that
a colony
yeah that's it Ukraine is a colony of
the United States
oh just wait I'll I'll count down until
I get the Russell Brand treatment
because I think I think the war machine
is the bigger reason why they're going
after Russell Brand people think it's
it's big Pharma I disagree and it's when
I look I mean 60 Minutes reports this so
maybe they'll go after who who does it
Scott Pelley is that who's doing 60
minutes I think so yeah maybe they'll go
after him he's gonna get accused that'll
be hilarious but uh the United States
your tax dollars are not going so that
Russia could to fight a war in Russia
your tax dollars are propping up small
businesses in Ukraine now ask yourself
why is CBS news reporting this Ukraine
is a colony of the United States which
means we pay for their public uh their
civilian public infrastructure First
Responders it means we subsidize their
small businesses and it means we cover
the cost of Defense that's that's an
American colony as far as I'm concerned
or call it NATO whatever you want but
the US U.S is what's what's paying for
all this I'm surprised that this is
actually being reported because I'm sure
this has been going on for the entire
time we've been sending the money we've
sent them I think 113 billion dollars
there's there's no way people genuinely
thought that was all going to a war
effort
I mean it's funny how they support small
businesses when they're in Ukraine but
on the US you know that's that's the
point I mean the US is in Decay we've
got crime running rampant but geez
that's frustrating isn't it I mean and
now we're supposed to go to the polls
right and we were saying people just
become crazy during election years but
how could you not when you know that you
suffered after everything that happened
during covet the economic turmoil that
small businesses small communities felt
because of this to know that this is how
Joe Biden decided to spend your tax
dollars it can't feel like anything but
a slap in the face worse than that
so how many people lost their businesses
how many people to shut down their
stores and get a job at Walmart and then
you find out that all of your hard work
and the money they took from you is
propping up a small business in Ukraine
that's more than a slap in the face that
that's sedition I mean that that is that
is I I you know you can argue it's not
really treason because treason has
specific parameters but it is something
for the government to take money and
resources from Americans and and who are
suffering and their businesses are
shutting down and send all of that over
to Ukraine for what
it's a complete lack of loyalty to the
American people of any part of the
country it's an occupation of the
American people and an extraction of
their resources to fund other countries
yeah it's like mercantilism in the
reverse we're just giving to the Colony
or we have an occupying political force
in the United States that's extracting
as much as possible before it implodes
I mean this is one of the reasons that
I'd love to see a Democratic
presidential debate because I'd love to
see Joe Biden number one have to talk
publicly at all but also have to answer
questions about things like this because
so far as long as the Democratic party
can keep it in the background and you
know certain fractions of the media will
talk about it certain people will talk
about it but ultimately the average
voter should know should see the dollar
amount of what is being sent abroad and
where it is going because it's not the
story of just we're helping poor Ukraine
it's being bullied by Russia there is a
much bigger cost and ultimately the
Biden Administration is going to pretend
that that's not happening for as long as
possible as will the Democratic party as
a whole I think the Republicans need to
talk about this in the debate stage as
well because I'm not convinced that if
another Republican not named Donald
Trump gets in there they're going to
stop funding I think it will just
continue yeah I wouldn't be surprised I
think uh if it's Vivek you'll see the
funding stop but Nikki Haley is the
inverse she's screaming with blood
spraying from her mouth that she wants
to block children in foreign countries I
despise that woman by the way these
people are all warmongers they can't
give a rational reasonable justification
for what for what they do what they want
what they're funding they just lie I
think was it Nikki Haley who lied and
said that uh Putin said Poland's next or
something like that yeah I think she
should have started that during the
during the the lesser-known Republican
debate something like that and this and
and you've got anti-war left and right
being like what is wrong with these
people their their their brains are not
right there is something wrong you want
to make an argument for intervention and
War you can make the argument you can
talk about Russia aligning with China
the U.S is trying to defend Ukraine and
stop Russia from gaining more resources
in Eastern Europe and expanding their
economic Stranglehold in the region as
they team up with Russia creates a very
big threat so the U.S try to push back I
know all that stuff I've heard all the
arguments but that's not the arguments
they make so long as they want to keep
lying about what they're doing then so
be it they deserve to lose
yeah but will they actually
lose I mean they've lost we had that one
report uh Adrian Norman wrote for
timcast.com uh well and to be fair was
it was um
was it Seymour Hersh I think it was a
report from him that he's speaking with
an intelligence official so Seymour has
reported an intelligent official said oh
it's over Russia won what did Russia
want they wanted the land bridge into
Crimea they got it now what now they
defend it yeah that's it so what what
are we doing there trying to stop them
if if the US's goal really here is to
just strip Russia Russia's access to
Crimea and the Mediterranean then it's
basically just the U.S declaring war on
Russia
no there's no end in sight which also
AIDS divide administration's continues
send money over I mean yeah there is
nothing in this for the American people
and so
I don't understand why we continue it it
costs them every single day and Russia
already has its main objective it
doesn't seem like a productive War but
we're gonna be there uh for as long as
the Democrat is in office and probably a
lot of Republicans do
um
a productive War yeah I think the last
one that we were in yeah so many
productive Wars in history but again
like at a certain point I mean the US
and the EU could say we're going to
broke a deal isn't this what Donald
Trump said he said day one I'm gonna
stop this war that would be the first
thing I did
the war will stop exactly where it is
exactly and Russia would say okay why is
no one else doing that right like why do
we have to keep doing this
I'm asking such deep questions tonight
on Tim cast IRL I'm stunning all of our
guests I mean do you guys know anyone
who's like yes this is a great idea let
us continue to send money to Ukraine not
at all no well I think among Democrats
it's still quite a popular position and
certainly in in uh in the EU and in UK
that remains a really popular position
but why what what is their objective
other than we just don't like Russia
well there's this whole apparatus in the
media that does put out the the
propaganda talking points from
Ukraine uh about this being more than
just
a war between two Nations a civil war
between Good and Evil and it's it's I
mean it's it's packaged in a way that's
simple for the masses and it works
there's a good side and a bad side and
it's popular uh among Democrats in the
US and uh liberal voters in Canada and
um liberal people in in Europe but is it
enough to outweigh the economic hardship
that people in the US are facing I mean
we were just talking about gas prices in
LA are crazy
this is your cost of living but also
we're still going to continue to fund
this war abroad it would be impossible
at least in my opinion for anyone who's
reasonable to say that's a good use of
our tax dollars I appreciate this
I think it's just a lot of people aren't
really paying attention to it they just
think it's something that's going on and
that
um that we're kind of supporting it and
it's the current thing but people when
you present the facts to them when you
say hey actually all this money's going
here they would say yeah you know easily
we should stop funding but nobody's
really presenting it to them so they're
not seeing the alternative yeah well
it's a Nuance
um issue and it's it's difficult I think
for the masses to comprehend and to come
up with an informed position it's
similar to the problems that arise from
immigration you know we know what it
does on the labor market what it does uh
how it makes housing crisis worse but
people by and large in urban areas don't
really push back on the policies of
sanctuary cities or or U.S immigration
policy in fact in these areas they're
the loudest in saying you know well have
them come in they want their cake and to
eat it too and they don't realize that
the balancing the books actually in the
end doesn't really work you're going to
suffer from one way or the other and
um
I yeah you know I mean this is really
the responsibility in the press to
present the truth on these issues to the
public but the the establishment Legacy
Media
um fails in that because they're
captured could you think the Legacy
meter would ever go back to having a
standard for truth or do you think it's
a lost lost cause
uh the journalism programs at the the
universities that lead to people going
into New York Times in Washington Post
and other places it's all
I mean these programs have long been
captured I don't I don't really know how
you can at this point do much so what's
the future of Legacy Media in your
opinion
gosh
um
I don't know I think all I mean what I
would like to see happen is
um independent and conservative media
having more support from philanthropist
for one
I mean it's it's really hard to get
Independent Media well-funded you know
riders need to be paid reporters
um need salaries and it's it's a lot of
work it's a lot of money to get that
type of stuff going and we just have to
build up these different institutions I
I guess you know I mean it's a cliche
what I'm saying but really it's it's
it's so important and I think what
causes a lot of
um
conservative or Independent Media to go
under is ultimately it's just the
funding's not there people want to get
their news for free everyone hates going
to a news link and then you have to log
in or you have to pay it or something
you know but um that or the experiences
filled with a whole bunch of ads and
that's not pleasant either but it's
unless you're Rumble and then there's no
Burger King ads and the left has more
than enough patrons so they will get
funding from powerful prominent
individuals who want to prop up the
system they'll pay millions of dollars
to websites that can't make a penny and
osoros has funded media as well of
course of course and then on the right
you just got the people who want to
contribute sign up and join and pay what
they can that's about it yeah but I
think there's been enough
stress on the system
and more people are waking up and
starting to join these subscription
programs and make contributions and I
think the Independent Media space is
becoming better at providing real
incentives and and real value to their
members and their customers yeah I was
at um Black Dog Coffee nearby on Friday
and someone came up to me and you know
I've only been on the show for a little
while so it doesn't happen all the time
but he was like Hey I love the work you
guys do and I was like oh gosh thanks so
much and he's like yeah where else am I
supposed to get my news which I found
really interesting it's telling uh
people rely on alternative media in a
way that even a decade ago they couldn't
have and in sort of like the sphere of
influencer marketing it's something no
one could have predicted because it's a
it's a break from the traditional model
built on technology that didn't exist 20
years ago thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time